na vida foi até fermento seu pensamento
faz crescer a massa e é por acreditar no
que disse neste haicai estou aqui diante
de vocês e trazendo restos pra gente
conversar conversa
o primeiro deles um poema chamado
cultura e sabedoria cultura é ensinar ao
menino a ler ea escrever palavras
sabedoria é ensinar lhe a vivenciar
sentidos cultura ensinar ele sobre as
coisas da natureza sabedoria é ensinar
lhe sobre a natureza das coisas cultura
ensinar a menina ver as horas sabedoria
é ensinar e a aproveitar se o tempo
cultura ensinar-lhe os atalhos do poder
e sabedoria é ensinar lhe uso os
caminhos da liberdade cultura é ensinar
aos meninos são mais riquezas ea
diminuir custos sabedoria é ensinar lhe
a multiplicação das virtudes ea divisão
por amor cultura ensinar-lhe a trabalhar
o corpo sabedoria é ensinar ele a salvar
a alma
e é por acreditar que o verso tem este
poder de alavancar de criar movimentos
que me associam o mova-se novo assim mas
com um sentido em relação ao próximo
o poema chama-se razão 2
se eu te ajudo não me ajude diz ajuda a
dois lá na frente e não aceite que te
ajudem que ajudem 4 pra frente que esses
quatro não aceitem a ajuda dos seus
seqüentes seguindo-se assim por diante
na razão da progressão sem que se quebre
a corrente e envolve o planeta a gente
com marília feita de gente pois mais que
corrente é maya de afeto e amor que se
espalha e logo logo se fecha e um mundo
todo agasalho e ao se completar a volta
são tantos a me ajudar e eu não preciso
de fato que volte se para me amparar
ampara dois lá na frente e de novo assim
por diante até não mais precisa
simples assim não é
mas um detalhe um detalhe capacidade de
cá de avançar mas sem correria
a proposta vem num poema que chamei
conselho caminhante das muitas jornadas
ao passar por aqui passa lento
é preciso te deixes pegadas na magia de
cada momento viajante do grande caminho
deste aqui para onde tu fores leva
dentro de ti um pouquinho do perfume de
todas as flores houve que ao longe a
fonte de chama a cantar o seu canto de
amor mas escuta a floresta reclama sente
pena de ti viajou por que a pressa que
tens vale nada é o tempo uma mera ilusão
o que vale na tua passada é o sentido
real dimensão
o destino não foge de ti passa lento
a verdade é quem diz para que possa
dizer
aprendi e ao passar por aqui
fui infeliz
e é assim que viu o poeta moça e
sacramento pra lá e pra cá só conversa
aqui só conversa ali e o coração do
menino que vem pra minha mão e ele
enxerga só peço uma coisa vou vivendo
assim mas não me perguntem quantos anos
tem
e sim quantas cartas mandei e recebe-se
mais jovem se mais velho o que importa
se ainda sou um fervilhar de sonhos se
não carrego o fardo da esperança morta
não me pergunta quantos anos tem
e sim quantos beijos troquei beijos de
amor
se a juventude em mim ainda é festa se
aproveito de tudo a cada instante e se
eu bebo da taça gota-a-gota hora então
pouco se me dá e gotha resta não me
pergunta quantos anos tenho mas terão
saber de mim se cria e filhos terão
saber de mim que obras eu fiz foram
saber de mim e amigos tenho alguém o
dinheiro tornar feliz não me pergunta
quantos anos tenho mas queiram saber de
mim que livros lhe queriam saber de mim
por onde andei queremos saber de mim
quantas histórias quanto os versos houve
quantos cantei e assim somente assim
todos vocês por mais brancos que estejam
meus cabelos por mais rugas que vejo no
meu rosto terão vontade de chamar me o
moço e ao me verem
passar aqui e ali não saberão ao certo
minha idade mas saberão por certo que eu
vivi
[Aplausos]
[Música]